my mom thought it was crazy when I told
her I was into underwater hockey and she
continues to think I'm crazy when I show
up with black eyes but she's also my
biggest fan one of other world
championships my name is tre ullberg and
I'm the captain of the u.s. women's
underwater hockey team
so underwater hockey's played six on six
and we're not wearing tanks just spins a
mask and snorkel the puck is weighed in
and sits on the bottom of the pool and
players use short one-handed stick to
play the puck
unlike ice hockey there's no goalie and
underwater hockey and the snorkel helps
you watch the play while you're
recovering on the surface but otherwise
you're holding your breath when you're
actually involved in the play
we take underwater hockey very seriously
the u.s. women's national team competed
in the World Championships there held
every two years and they bring in about
25 different countries to compete to be
the best of the best it really is the
ultimate team sport because there's no
package that can just do everything for
your team eventually that person's going
to have to come up to breathe and you
have to have a teammate there to take
your place if I'm about to score and I'm
running out of air I'm in a freaking
score we see people coming to underwater
hockey both from swimming backgrounds
and from ice hockey backgrounds we
struggle from the fact that most people
in the United States don't grow up
playing it people don't grow up holding
their breath and trying to kick hard
underwater they grow up playing soccer
and playing basketball
there's no no money in underwater hockey
so we're absolutely doing it for the
loves of sport I love underwater hockey
it's so elegant being underwater it is
just a beautiful thing I feel like some
really gorgeous sea creature when I play
when I tell people I'm a pro football
player there's always a look of like
astonishment I get laughter sometimes
too and you know there's tournaments for
that use ball yeah that's the one that's
that's what I do
foosball is not just a barroom game it's
a competitive sport that's played at a
professional level by people all around
the world so it's like a hand-to-hand
combat you're standing this close you
know you're standing three feet away
from your opponent and it's almost like
you're in a fight you're battling
against each other I come from a long
line of foosball players I got into
foosball because of my dad he played in
the the golden era the 1970s when there
was a million dollar tour I've been
playing for 20 years now so for the
first 10 to 12 years of my career I
would practice on a table at home it
would be complete repetition over and
over and over every player in here can
execute it a shot
or a pass but it's a matter of
constructing a solid game plan it's like
a game of chess on the mental side it's
it it could be pretty taxing physically
by the end of the weekend you're sore
your hands are sore your feet are sore
so you have to be in decent shape I
always get a sweat band on my arm just
in case I get into a heated match I get
a you know wipe my brow so I go to the
World Cup which is basically our version
of the Olympics and I compete on Team
USA
I do believe it should be in the
Olympics our only problem is the fact
that there's not a standardized foosball
table and I'll do whatever it takes to
for the sport to reach that next level
bottom line is it makes me happy that
this is what I do and yeah I love it
how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything we have
the opportunity to do something that no
one else does this isn't played anywhere
else in the world so yeah like it's
serious like we want to win
we're here to watch unicycle football
it's football on unicycles we stick the
NFL rules as closely as possible so
there's a few exceptions goes riding a
unicycle we play five on five two
receivers a blocker a Center in a
quarterback everything has to be done on
a wheel the second your foot touches the
ground you're done HT plays 14 games 56
regular season games total the wild-card
playoffs and playoffs and then the Super
Bowl every Sunday some people have been
doing this for 10 years now my team the
blackout's were undefeated and we're
going to be playing the reigning champs
the herons bulldoze them over bulldoze
this game is very important because we
want to maintain our undefeated status
leading up to the Super Bowl
they're definitely gunning for us
they're practicing just for us
I think that a lot of times people come
to this game what shocks them is the
level of play we're crashing at 15 miles
an hour it's not a joke
some people get seriously injured most
people learn to ride unicycle because
they came and witnessed this event and
they're like I've got to do this once
you catch that first ball once you get
that first brush once you hear the crowd
scream your name once that's a feeling
you can't get anywhere else
that's almost like a religion church to
us here there's passion you know it's a
show it's a spectacle it's also a sport
I've cherished every minute of it can't
replace it anything there's nothing else
like it at all
there is nothing leisurely about
competitive eating this is an aerobic
activity it's like running a marathon
and a hundred yard dash at the same time
except your feet are standing still but
your stomach is moving it up 100 miles
an hour
my name is Crazy Legs Conti I've been a
major league eater for 15 years I cannot
think of a single food that has not gone
competitively into my stomach
make no mistake competitive eating is a
real sport it's muscle memory your
stomach mind and body has it
if you've prepared well enough what can
go wrong or not the voices in your
stomach but the voices in your head
you're getting full hot this is going
forever when will this end your strategy
has to be spot-on in terms of your
technique but you don't actually taste
the food at about 15 I start to feel the
drag on peristalsis and my system in
competitive eating we call it the wall
that's where your body just says stop
you're sweating your cheeks are puffed
out you're exhausted the last two
minutes are where dreams are made and
realities are broken that's the most
difficult part of any contest there is
no magic in the aftermath of competitive
eating we digest everything we eat I
need to continually drink liquids to
kind of create a log flume likeability
in my system the minimum for any
competitive eating contest is 24 hours
before I feel human and by human I mean
as a casual diner again I find the
activity of competitive eating to be
grueling and challenging and esoteric
but rewarding I'm going to eat for the
rest of my life I might as well do it
competitively
you probably remember this hilarious
moment from When Harry Met Sally and she
tells all huh Stein's guitar stars while
this ridiculous rom-com scene is
indicative of a real and very serious
sport which Believe It or Not introduced
society to sport betting competitive
walking better known to some as
pedestrianism started in the 1800s
aristocrats at that time had footmen
whose job was to carry messages from one
aristocratic to another it was only a
matter of time until the aristocrats
started making wagers on whose footmen
was faster
thus the birth of sport betting as we
know it competitive walking grew into a
real sporting event and reached its peak
in the 1870s and 1880s when spectators
would show up in super bowl-like masses
to see people walk competitively they've
even filled up the original Madison
Square Garden well sometimes races would
last up to six days in the atmosphere
was almost festival like brass bands
played vendors sold pickled eggs maybe
even some roasted chestnuts YUM the
competition's drew everyone from
celebrities to politicians even regular
folk champagne of all things was the
drink of choice for walkers they thought
it was a stimulant and as one would they
drank it by the bottle and guess what it
kind of worked one guy walked 136 miles
in just 34 hours bottoms up